le reste de l'actualité en france avant
les fêtes de fin d'année la sécurité a
été renforcée à paris comme chaque année
les lieux sensibles font l'objet d'une
vigilance particulière
il s'agit notamment des grands magasins
mais aussi des champs elysées où un
jeune homme a été tué il ya quinze jours
lors d'un affrontement entre bandes
rivales jérôme soûlard guillaume viard
voici l'heure des cadeaux des reds et
des lumières dans les grands quartiers
commerçants de paris trois cent mille
touristes chaque jour sur les champs
elysées qu'il faut rassurer grâce à un
renfort de policiers plus nombreux plus
visible elle n'a pas eu de problème
il s'est promené ici sur les champs
elysées les jours et même de nuit et
tout s'est bien passé elle pas de
problème et pourtant ces dernières
années la plus grande avenue du monde a
été quelquefois le lieu de rixe entre
bandes de jeunes rivales comme ici en
l'an 2000 il y a deux semaines
ce jeune homme est ainsi mort poignardé
en pleine journée au milieu de touristes
affolé ce renfort de policiers annoncé
et donc apprécié par les commerçants de
se sentir quelque part un petit peu
rassuré par rapport à ce genre
d'événement parce que ce genre
d'événement forcément n'est pas n'est
pas très bon par rapport par rapport à
la politique après que
on peut donner sur les champs-elysées
donc je pense que c'est nécessaire
trente quatre patrouilles mobilisait à
paris jusqu'en janvier
ce matin le ministre de l'intérieur est
venu en personne présenter son
dispositif
ce sont 1500 policiers qui sont déployés
pour ce dispositif spécifique des fêtes
du 1er décembre au 15 janvier date de la
période de fin des soldes
donc vous voyez quand on veut
véritablement dans cette période
assurer la sécurité maximale pour paris
ainsi que d'ailleurs pour les grandes
villes de province 2 million de
personnes sont attendues sur les
champs-elysées la semaine prochaine
beaucoup de monde beaucoup d'argent et
plus de policiers cette année à paris
les fêtes de noël sont sous haute
surveillance